Jamie will be you telling me the Conor McGregor was mad at me for something.
What were you saying?
I can pull up the video.
I guess.
What was he doing?
Is that illegal?
Are we allowed to see it?
Fine?
What did he say?
Something like a script.
I talk off script,
talk on script or call fights on a script or something.
That is not really true because no one ever gives me a script.
That's a fact.
I mean,
I don't know what exactly he said,
but maybe just didn't like my commentary.
I bet he likes it when he wins.
Right.
You know,
when you guys picture in your,
uh,
right here in the,
what do you call this place in the studio?
The actual quote is I'd like him to call a fight.
Always sees it correctly instead of reading off a script though.
Uh,
well that's,
that's,
you know,
that's his perception.
I understand what he's saying.
You all,
sometimes people think that,
but you know,
it's very difficult when someone's calling your fight.
If he's talking about me calling someone's fight that's not his friend,
then that,
that makes much more sense.
It's fucking hard,
man.
I,
it's hard for me.
It's a,
I have a really hard time calling friends fights.
It's fucking hard.
I don't know him that well,
but I like him a lot.
I respected fun to watch him fight.
That's for sure.
Do me to play the clip.
Yeah,
sure.
Go ahead.
Play it
right.
He's got a great photo when things got crazy insight.
Great guests.
Maybe it's [inaudible] you the flight haven't seasoned.
Correct.
[inaudible] he was leading up the worst flight.
The phasers guys slept for Mcgregor
the same way is too close and [inaudible] talks maybe until today.
So he's talking about there.
Must have asked him if you do the podcast.
Yeah,
I kid his position.
Uh,
you know that Dee has fight was good fucking fight,
man.
It's a hard fight.
I wasn't calling it like the last fight,
but I had to call it with the knowledge of the last fight.
I had to know what happened in the last fight.
In the last fight,
Diaz survived the storm,
tagged him,
hadn't Brockton then finished him on the ground.
It doesn't mean that he didn't win the second fight.
It was close fucking fight.
The second fight was a very close fight.
But you have to acknowledge that that of the fight took place.
So he also said it like with a smile.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You could tell the man.
I think that guy is one of the most dynamic individuals to ever compete in the
sport.
He's a special person.
Very special person.
Very unusual guy.
Even if he doesn't beat Khabib ever again,
or you know,
he loses to this guy loses to the Floyd Mayweather.
Lou,
who cares?
He's still one of a fucking billion human being.
He's an unusual guy.
The amount of electricity,
it's fucking good,
man.
He starched Josie Aldo was one of the greatest featherweights,
if not the greatest,
next to Max Holloway of all times.
Starched him with one punch.
When Aldo was Aldo,
Aldo was the fucking man.
I mean,
he was the man.
He was smashing everybody for years and Connor talks so much shit to him.
He climbed so deep inside his head and infuriated him to the point where we're
so emotional and he came charging at Connor and Connor just slipped back and
bank drop like the best one punch knockout in the history of the sport.
Oh no shit.
Oh,
100% because it was so significant.
There was so much hype behind it.
It,
it was a a guy.
We were like,
how good is this guy's this guy really the next big thing or is he going to fall
apart when he meets a real champion like Aldo?
And then he knocks him out with one fucking punch black.
It was crazy.
And then hammer fist annoys out when he's on the ground.
I mean it was definitive,
right?
14 seconds,
40 seconds to seconds of the first round.
He throws a hopping sidekick.
He's gaging the distance.
He's got like this karate stance and then he sees josé load up here.
You can watch it right here.
He sees Josie load up and when he sees Josie load up,
he,
he had this fight.
One Guy,
he had this fight one even before.
I mean,
he knew how it was going to go down.
He knew what all those going to do.
He was real emotional and angry,
so he knew he was going to come forward.
So he's gauging is distance.
Why pain?
See that Bam.
Oh,
the Friday one.
It's,
I mean,
that was like one of the most spectacular chaos in the history of the sport
because it had so much meaning to it.
It was so important.
It was for the featherweight champion of the world.
Conard already won the interim title him and although facing each other,
this big hype thing took her a year to put together crazy so that he's awesome.
Did you call that?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I think he's the only time I've ever yelled out.
He slept him when someone got cracked because it's just,
I don't even know why I said,
it's just like that's,
that's what came to my head.
I just,
I just yelled it out.
He said that's cause that's what he did.
He slept him.